at 4 p.m last friday just after prayers
residents of the palestine apartments
were eating or sleeping on their day off
when the israelis struck it from above
their target taisir al-jabri was
visiting relatives on the sixth floor
a commander in militant group islamic
jihad he was killed in the attack
but al-jabri wasn't the only person in
the building
the abu ramadans lived directly below
this is the
this is the apartment of the abu ramadan
family but there is not much
left of it
in fact it's totally destroyed
a family of six they were all injured in
the attack
mother naveen suffered extensive
shrapnel wounds and she may lose her leg
you cannot imagine i cannot imagine
it is very deep
grandmother rabab is trying to look
after her and the rest of the family
she and her husband were sleeping on the
on their face
the ceiling
broken on their legs on their
yes and the ceiling also the ground
broken on the other neighbors
so they fell through onto their
naveen's daughter islam was in the
operating theater during our visit
doctors at gaza's central hospital
trying to remove blood clots that had
formed in her body
these pictures were taken just after the
attack on the palestine apartment
complex
local residents telling us it was hit by
four missiles
the israelis say they do everything they
can to avoid civilian casualties
but that's not a realistic proposition
in a building like this
we found maha and her seven-year-old
twins in the same hospital ward
sarah and yara were praying in the
living room with their father when their
home was destroyed by an explosion on
friday night
[Music]
both daughters have broken legs and
shrapnel wounds
yara has just left intensive care
the israelis say some explosions were
caused by malfunctioning rockets fired
by islamic jihad but mahat doesn't
believe it they're always targeting us
she says
john sparks sky news in gaza